there's almost a
natural a natural kind of defense
mechanism that people have when it comes
to I think I think especially in the UK
I feel like Americans have less of this
defense at least from what I've seen at
conferences any a sort of a natural
defense to anything that seems even
remotely like oh this person's trying to
tell me what to do or they're trying to
promise something that's too big and
this sort of natural this skepticism
that we have towards following the
advice of someone who's been there and
done that and we don't have that
skepticism when it comes to a tennis
lesson or a guitar teacher but we have
that skepticism when it comes to a sales
coach or marketing coach or business
coach or anything remotely in the make
money realm why any any thoughts on that
um I think it's down to just um what our
pre preconceived ideas are about that
thing like you kind of know a little bit
about like if you're going to show up to
a tennis lesson you know that you're
probably going to have to run about a
bit and swing your Racket and hit a few
balls right so that you kind of got a
preconceived idea about it I think to a
lot of people there is a certain element
of mystery around what business is what
it means and I I always say to people
like um you you can do the website and
the The Branding and the domain names
and the all of all of the things like
the goal setting the business planning
all that sort of stuff but 90% of
everything you need to learn about
business you will get from just getting
out there and selling something and it
doesn't matter whether it's 20 to mow
somebody's lawn if it's a a TW you know
a six-month transformational dating
program um it doesn't matter what it is
get out there and sell something for
some money and see how you feel about it
afterwards it's as simple as that you'll
learn 90% of everything you need to know
because within having to do that you had
to Market because you had to make
somebody aware that you had a program to
sell or that you had a lawn mower to
push around somebody's Garden or
whatever it might be yeah um you had to
sell something because you had to have
that awkward conversation okay yeah I'm
interested you Mar my loan but how much
is it going to cost well I'll do it for
20 quid oh gosh well my my my Gardener
charges £15 an hour why are you so much
better so you in that sales process you
learn something about yourself and about
your processes and your business and all
those sorts of things uh then you move
into you know on boarding client on
boarding what you know giving somebody
the next steps you know what's their
first session what does that look like
um uh what time am I going to show up
with my lawnmower um then it moves into
client fulfillment you know actually
doing the work um uh at the end of it
the the doing the work is tricky cuz if
unless you're getting feedback
throughout it if somebody's watching
over you whilst they mow the lawn and
they have a go at you because your
stripes aren't quite right on the lawn
or whatever or maybe in the coaching
program somebody sat there're a bit
confused and saying well I don't think
that's going to work for me because I
don't want to use that app for my dating
because um for whatever reason um so you
might get some feedback within the
Fulfillment but then at the end of it
you can then see well does the client
pay you and are they happy or do do they
not pay you are they unhappy and leave
negative reviews but within that what
can I learn from it yeah fa step-by-step
process yeah basically but along the way
for some reason in people's head there's
Peril oh what if I put my marketing out
there and it doesn't work what if I sell
some try and sell something and they say
no what if I try and onboard the client
and then they Backtrack on the agreement
what if I try and start doing the thing
and find that I'm not very good at it uh
what if I when I've done it and I'm not
very good at it I get a negative review
all this Peril you know think about
Harry Potter and the Journeys that he
goes through there Adventures there's
Peril all along the way in there but
again it comes back to what's the two
things that could go wrong in business
you look a bit stupid or you end up
losing a bit of money and actually
neither of them are that bad in the
grand scheme of things hey friends thank
you so much for watching if you enjoyed
this clip then click here for the full
unedited episode and if you like that
then do please consider subscribing to
the channel it means a lot thank you so
much and have a great day bye-bye